Dave Portnoy is a sports guy he's
obviously the founder of Barstool Sports
sports media giant online gambling giant
also an investor he joins us on set now
to us so that's really the thank you
Dave for coming that's really the
question you are uh I don't know how to
describe your investing but it's
something you do on the side yeah but
you're into it yep so you're not like a
trained expert FDX was an Advertiser of
ours exactly but you're an enthusiast
what I mean was this obvious to you that
there's something weird going on no I
don't know how it could be obvious to
anybody a normal citizen I mean if you
see Tom Brady pitching FTX on the Super
Bowl you're probably going to believe
it's a legitimate thing I mean I I don't
know why you want it as the stories have
come out in crypto you know I'm not
paying a ton attention there is articles
I think coindesk wrote it the thing
that's shocking to me and I I'm in the
gambling field we're rigorously
regulated like they know what I did 20
years ago yes everything I if I do one
thing weird I hear about it there's
companies writing articles we knew this
guy was in the Bahamas why because it's
unregulated living in basically a Paula
Morris Penthouse with like 20 people who
are all having sex with each other
running this and it was well known I
mean if somebody did that in the United
States and meanwhile he's converting
with politicians at the highest level of
government the fact he wasn't
investigated to me just shows what this
a lot of this country is all about
people are just trying to make money
they're being dishonest they're saying
the right things to make money and he's
lining everybody's Pockets it wasn't
obvious to me but if you're meeting with
Gensler in your meeting with politicians
I
I know in a million years they didn't
know that
um it was pretty obvious it wasn't a
welcome I mean I wasn't looking for it
but once you start going back it's like
holy cow how did they not know this
again contrast that with like what I go
through because people don't like me in
his night and day I mean it really is
quite Stark so no not not a normal
person who is investing whatever no
Steph Curry Tom Brady it's the Miami
arena down here is FTX a normal person
got taken advantage of basically right
and where's the government for example
an offshore Casino they can't advertise
in the Super Bowl we can't take money
from them that's all illegal why was FDX
legal why could they advertise who's
regulating that that's amazing where the
real big problem is it's because the guy
is spending millions and millions and
millions of dollars to grease the right
Wheels it also seems like now that it's
failed in this spectacular way that
failure will be used as a justification
for massive regulation 100 and you
mentioned it he was the guy supposedly
helping craft the regulation for future
crypto which is insane are you looking
at his background at all to do that it
will be because what you said money
wants to control the money and if you do
crypto right I think in the long term
this will be good for Bitcoin but it
it's hard to control so I think a lot of
people politicians whatever looked at
this guy hey if we partner up with him
we can make sure we have our hands in
the pie and kind of control what's going
on also side note these politicians are
deleting the photos with them that's
like the dumbest thing I've ever seen
what do you think people don't know you
took a photo with them you delete them
it's out there I don't You could argue
how hard is it to control photos once
they're on the internet Dave uh they're
gone I mean listen nobody knows more
than me
I
and but that's
Paul doing it's like I can't walk down
the street if I hold a girl's hand it's
a story what's Dave doing this guy is
it's like a x-rated movie out in the
Bahamas and nobody cared it's like what
are you doing and I'm not even I don't
care about judge but nobody looked into
it they're just looking the other way
taking pictures taking his money he's
like you said the number two uh donor
for the Democrats not one word not one
peep and to be honest if this didn't
fall apart if the finance guy who's a
Savage didn't do this rumor and probably
create the Run nobody would ever know
he'd be the altruistic guy nobody's
altruistic nobody all the crap everybody
says whether a politician is for power
money most of the time people want to
get rich and I trust the guys weirdly
like me it is me
I've always I want to make money I want
to spend money I want to have a great
life this guy I want to make money give
it away no you weren't he he took a loan
for himself he was paying for the
penthouse through the company money he
was doing whatever he wanted and nobody
took two seconds to look two SEC I
talked to him by the way
um when they advertised he was always a
weird guy like this charm and all that
stuff no way he was the least Charming
guy really I've ever spoken no there
wasn't like oh my God this guy's some
sort of Genius maybe he he arbitrized
like the with an MIT degree to make some
money but he wasn't some charming guy
you Charmed the pants off people he
couldn't charm anybody you know how he
Charmed him with his wallet money
donations and they looked the other way
there is no other explanation for that
I'm far more Charming in a one-on-one
sit down than he is and you know what I
end up at the front end of a hit piece
every two weeks that's because I'm not
writing checks
do you think I mean I guess it's
unknowable but just having watched this
for a while will we ever really get to
the bottom of what happened no no I mean
listen they say that he had this
research fund they loaned all the money
and then the binance guy CZ binance
whatever his name they were competitors
and he and it's all crypto some of it's
magic but
I don't know that will truly know what
happened because there's a lot big
players have probably lost a lot of
money I mean the bankruptcy today what
they release is crazy what they're
spending money on but who knows I never
think we'll know anything I don't want
to be some conspiracy when there's big
money involved I never think I'm getting
a straight shake like I mean honestly
how can Gensler sit down with a guy who
is living in a penthouse in the Bahamas
with 15 people who are all having sex
with each other spending money on
everything and he's like yeah we're
going to write the legislation with you
I mean honestly
how is that possible I can't tie my shoe
this guy's doing that and get away with
like come on to the White House let's
sit down and you know make some
legislation it's insane you need to
spread some donations around Dave
Portnoy that's my call Maxine Waters and
fund your next campaign today fortnite
what a great explanation thank you thank
you
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight